Hey, welcome back to 40 Days of Holiness. Grab your workbook.
If you don't have one, of course, you can go to
www.40daysofholiness.com and grab yours.
Here's today's theme on day number six,
"God saves his people from slavery for
holiness."
I want to call out today a little lie that exists in many people's
heads, and here's what it is. "I have to be holy and get my act together
so God will want me and love me and save me."
No, not true. That's a lie. Now, wait a minute.
I thought we were just saying this whole thing was about holiness.
This is God's main point. It's what he's trying to produce in us.
That's true.
He is trying to create that in your life and your heart. So what happened to that?
Well, let me teach you something really, really valuable.
You have to understand this. Salvation
is by grace
for holiness. God saved his people from slavery
before they were holy in his sight.
He delivered them from slavery because of his kindness to them, not
because they had their act together. They were mixed up.
They were stubborn in a million ways.
They were not holy, but he delivered them anyway, and
we call that grace.
Now, I want you to notice that God did not try to leave them in slavery and
teach them holiness. Instead, he brought them out,
and then he takes them to the mountain, the children of Israel.
He brings them out of slavery in Egypt and takes them to Mount Sinai and teaches
them holiness. He makes his covenant.
That's where he says, "I am the Lord your God.
Be holy because I am." The exodus from Egypt came before
the covenant of holiness. Deliverance was all about
grace, but it was for the purpose of holiness.
Your salvation is not because you've been good or you've been holy.
It was completely and totally of grace.
No contribution of goodness on your part at all.
God did it because of past promises he made to
display his glory as a saving, faithful God.
He made promises to Abraham, and he's keeping those.
He made promises to Jesus, and he's keeping those.
Your salvation was by grace, but your salvation is
for the purpose of holiness. So since I don't know
everybody that's watching this and going through this 40-day journey with me, I
have to make sure you understand.
Holiness isn't so God will love you.
It's not so that God will save you.
The covenant of holiness God makes between him and his people, and that's
you and me,
is coming after he delivers us from bondage and slavery to
sin. So the first thing that I have to ask you is
this. Have you been saved? Have you trusted
in Jesus and been saved from the penalty of sin by
faith in his blood?
Now, if you've been thinking, "Well, I'm going to get holy and then God's going to
be pleased and save me," then you've got it exactly
backwards. You're saved by grace
for holiness. God wants to save you not because of any
holiness or goodness that you've gotten a hold of,
but because of his kindness and his grace showered on us through
Jesus Christ. Ephesians 2:8-9 says this,
"For it is by grace you have been saved, through faith—and this is
not of yourselves, it is the gift of
God—not of works so that no one can boast."
Now, if you're saved, you're not wrong to pursue holiness.
In fact, it's the most natural thing in the world to chase
after if God's really saved you. The next verse after the one I just
read, Ephesians 2:10, says, "For we are God's handiwork,
created in Christ Jesus to do good works, which God
prepared in advance for us to do." You see the progression?
You're saved by grace for good works, by grace
for holiness. Now, don't miss this.
Holiness is part of the gospel. It is the result
of, it is the natural progression of the gospel.
Some people treat salvation by faith like that's the gospel.
It's the good news, and holiness is like it's the irrelevant news.
Don't do that. Your salvation, the whole point of it is
for holiness. It's not just some eternal fire insurance where down the road you can
be with Jesus when you die. It's for the purpose of holiness now.
God takes his people out of Egypt, then takes them to Sinai to make
his covenant of holiness with them and to teach them about
him.
So it's the most natural thing in the world once you're saved to start
pursuing holiness because that's literally
what God saved you for. So
if you're just realizing that you're not saved, no problem.
Let's get that set straight right now, immediately.
Trust in Jesus today. Repent of sin.
Leave your life of slavery to sin and death.
Do it right now because he's good and because he's kind, not
because you're holy and you've got it all together.
Jesus is your Moses. Let him lead you out of the land of slavery
and bondage and lead you to his kingdom.
He's here to do it now, not wait until you've got your act together.
But if you are already saved and you know you are, you know you're right with
God, then realize this.
God didn't save you for heaven or some eternal fire insurance or
because he felt sorry for you. He saved
you for holiness. That's what's
next. So let's keep moving forward.
Let's keep pursuing holiness together because that's the whole point of
why God saved you.
I'll see you tomorrow. Make sure you do your workbook. Don't forget.
Don't
skip over it. Take some time to think through, fill in blanks,
think through the meditation questions because God's got work he's doing in you
through the Holy Spirit. And so let me just encourage you to keep on going.
Don't stop. Keep pushing forward. I'll see you tomorrow.